will destroy our case four guys standing
next to the door shouting at me and my
friend losing here we're walking
together saying hey coronavirus and they
do the gesture covering their nose and
the mouth was a colorful shirt and then
laughing out loud Chinese students Robin
and Lucy are the latest victims of
racist abuse linked to the corona virus
shouted out in Cardiff City Center are
heading to lectures I feel very sad and
also I don't know how to react at that
time but I think the virus is problem
that everyone has to face while we were
filming someone shouts at their friend
Sarah she's from Wuhan and it's not the
first time that she's had abuse for
wearing a mask
my parents are worried about me and well
one made to wear masks even I in the in
the UK I'm really first training the one
somebody just showed me Crona Royals
these students are part of a growing
number facing hostility there have also
been reports of abuse in Sheffield
Leicestershire York and Manchester over
kovat 19 the official name now given to
the virus the Chinese ambassador to the
UK has told Sky News that he has raised
the issue of hatred and discrimination
with the British government but it's not
just University students other Chinese
nationals in the UK have been forced to
go to the police ever concerns about
racism if this was a private message
sent to our Facebook page the disgusting
barbaric animal cruelty you people do
you deserve to get the virus Kate Gordon
helps run the Chinese Community Centre
in Birmingham
although abuse is rare it is increasing
and is even forced some Chinese workers
in the city to change their
routine very very aware now that if you
stand on a tram or a train or a bus and
their coffee will sniffing people people
looking at us so I feel very conscious
and some of us have started to change
our work hours so we're not traveling
during peak leave hours just to avoid
this kind of very negative and and quite
hostile environment staff at the Chinese
supermarket in Birmingham's Chinese
quarter wear masks the manager tells us
simply to protect everyone we actually
don't want to wear the Moscow but we
need to protect ourself and there's a
protective people here we don't want to
make a trouble through this culture so
that's why we're in Moscow to protect
protected Erik everybody here as the
number of coronavirus cases goes up in
the UK soda reports of abuse this is
making lives for many Chinese already
worried about families back home even
harder dan whited Sky News